en su primera salida internacional la
nueva jefe del gobierno italiano Georgia
meloni llegó a Bruselas con un mensaje
moderado mostrando una postura
europeísta y adventista Italia quiere
participar dijo colaborar y defender el
interés nacional italiano dentro de la
Unión Europea afirmó meloni al culminar
la jornada de encuentros con los
presidentes de la comisión Europea el
consejo europeo y el parlamento europeo
Con quienes abordó una agenda marcada
por la crisis energética y la inflación
la líder de la ultraderecha Italiana
evocó la guerra en Ucrania y su impacto
en la economía italiana abogó por una
solución europea concreta para
contrarrestar el aumento del precio de
la energía evocó Igualmente el espinoso
tema de una posible revisión de los
recursos del fondo de recuperación
europea post pandemia recordemos Italia
es el estado que más dinero europeo va a
recibir unos 200 mil millones de en
préstamos y subvenciones de la ue otro
tema delicado la inmigración en
declaraciones a la prensa melón y
confirmó que Durante los encuentros
abogó por una mayor defensa de las
fronteras externas de la unión euro